dans l'est de montréal la popote
roulante est l'une des rares encore
ouverte
les repas préparés ici nourrissent une
cinquantaine de personnes âgées
complètement isolé c'est qu'à partir de
demain on va éviter d'aller trop souvent
chez les gens pour être certain que
personne ne manque de rien le chef a
préparé des dizaines de repas congelés
pour les livreurs le mot d'ordre est
clair aucun contact physique avec les
clients ce genre de service
communautaire c'est le dernier rempart
pour que les plus vulnérables ne soient
pas coupés du reste du monde pour
s'assurer que les aînés isolés ne manque
de rien julian forfait multiplient les
appels à l'ossétie à l'os et julian
saveur elle parle à cécile une dame de
81 ans d'infecter moins stressés bombe
qui pour l'épicerie été correct et
économistes est la plus stressée de la
guerre l'organisme de julian forte
organise actuellement un service pour
faire des courses préparer et livrer des
épiceries en raison de la crise
les organismes communautaires ont perdu
beaucoup de bénévoles les personnes
aînées c'est la majorité je voudrais de
nous nos bénévoles pour les organismes
communautaires donc les organes et se
retrouvent sans ressource pour ça mais
dans la communauté de plus en plus de
gens proposent leur aide
on s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
faire à aider notre communauté en nyanza
ce groupe facebook
plus de mille personnes ont offert leurs
services sur la page facebook lancé par
ariane marche 1 et j'en ai envie d'aider
sont enthousiastes ont envie de santé
qui font partie d'une communauté ou six
filles de santé la solidarité autour
d'eux cette initiative a permis à julian
forte est de recruter 10 nouveaux
bénévoles
en moins de 24 heures s'est créé le vrai
comme un esprit collectif les gens
veulent aider on y compte à un élan de
solidarité née d'une crise dont on ne
connaît pas encore la durée ici vincent
maisonneuve réseau canada montréal